j'ai 34 ans ancien mannequin vous
publiez votre cinquième livre chez
flammarion ça s'appelle presque top
model alors évidemment pendant les
nombreux temps mort de votre ancien job
vous avez observé vous avez pris des
notes élevées attendues votre heure est
ce étonnant roman informés et pertinents
sur le monde de la mode dans le style de
beigbeder voire de bret easton ellis et
je ne suis pas avare de compliments mais
je m'avance mais je pense vraiment je
pense merci beaucoup c'est très très
bien écrit
or le pitch passé le destin croisé
disons de deux mannequins de top model
l'ascension d'une dénommée maryvonne et
la chute d'une dénommée susanna voilà il
ya peu d'un trip quand même vous dites
dans la mode dramaturgie et quotidienne
il n'y a ni début ni fin tout revient
comme un ressac absolument c'est un
éternel recommencement et mon lit ça se
passe pendant six mois les coulisses de
des milieux de la mode et c'est vrai
qu'au départ il ya une fille qui
débarque de sa bretagne natale elle et
personne ne le regarde avec un profond
mépris et puis finalement du jour au
lendemain elle va devenir quelqu'un et
c'est ça la mode en permanence le lundi
vous êtes vous n'êtes rien du tout le
mardi est un frémissement le mercredi on
vous dorlote on vous sublimer puis j'ai
dit vous êtes c'est le star system quoi
vous êtes
la plus grande voilà alors il ya des
scènes finalement c'est une succession
de scènes autour de trois grandes
familles de la mode les mannequins leurs
agents et les rédactrices de mode on
pense un peu un bouquin sorti l'année
dernière s'appelle le diable s'habille
en prada rebbah c'est une belle
comparaison celle que ce serait que le
diable s'habille en prada c'était
surtout sur une rédactrice de mode au
vogue et moi j'ai plutôt voulu parler
agence de mannequins des mannequins de
ce que c est ce que c'était que la vie
d'un mannequin aujourd'hui parce que
finalement c'est très fantasmé qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un top model c'est très
fantasmé mais c'est assez méconnue on
sait pas exactement ce que c'est que la
réalité de ces de ses villas c'est
terrible ouais c'est horrible c'est
vraiment horrible à la baisse et du
bétail et puis et puis c'est très
difficile parce que les filles et la
plupart du temps elles viennent de demi
de vladivostok où un de bucarest elles
ont 14 ans 15 ans et elle habite à paris
dans des chambres de bonne et puis moi
même enfin moi quand j'ai commencé
j'avais 21 ans j'étais j'étais très
âgées j'étais déjà une antiquité mais
c'est grisant quoi on vous dit tu vas
voir ma chérie je veux faire de toi une
star ça va être incroyable
et puis et puis ces dépôts fille et puis
on a peut-être une qui va qui va sortir
du lot et encore pendant quelques mois
parce qu'aujourd'hui les top models ça
n'existe plus parce qu'aujourd'hui si je
vous dis linda evangelista naomi
campbell et kate moss évidemment on sait
on sait qui est le sien ce sera
mannequin toute sa vie on est à peu près
sûr de ça c'est séné mannequin mourra
même qu'un et d'ailleurs elle a eu tout
le monde à ses pieds à l'époque où elle
était avec johnny depp pour faire du
cinéma de sonia voulait pas être ce
qu'elle voulait c'était faire la fête
j'étais en train de réussir un truc
assez difficile finalement c'est
l'ancien mannequin qui devient écrivain
quoi oui mais je crois que c'est en tout
cas celui ci prouve que c'est réussi
apparemment d'après les premiers et les
premiers retours jugé critique houeix
excellence et c'est formidable les
parents lire un boulet parce que la
seule façon de parler de littérature
était des licences et de la lyre
alors
tom et jerry ont embarqué deux
mannequins débutants kim suédoises 1 m
75 donne un petit côté kim basinger
trash grazzia argentine 1 m 72 et 45 kg
sac compris une salma hayek cadavérique
perchée sur des échasses tokyo à leur
première expérience peut-être la
dernière quatre cas style à shibuya line
sur des kilomètres un break chez daiei
pour un potage pékinois et une boule au
gingembre cette graine si la gare de
shinjuku la foule pressée le retour à
l'âge ans pour faire le point aucun
request pour le lendemain trois nouveaux
castings et saint guen si les filles
jubile elles préparent déjà leur des
leurs plans cherche les stations de
métro les plus proches décident de
déjeuner chez ito yokado plus près du
rendez vous dès midi elles partageront
un potage aux champignons noirs et une
boule coco puis retourneront à l'agencé
avec l'enthousiasmé l' optimisme à toute
épreuve des débutantes susanna ne veut
pas retomber dans cet anonymat les
salles d'attenté avec des centaines de
mineurs agrippa leur book rempli de test
et de composites avec des mensurations
tricks et les toilettes pour pleurer
snif et se maquiller le doute le
réconfort d'état jean tu as quelque
chose en plus tu spécial tu veux exposer
je le sens je sais ton avenir est tout
tracé dans un mois tu pars pour new york
et tu rafle la mise les filles s'endette
s'accroche se désespère suis à la haine
les traitements de faveur gianfranco
ferré l'on brasse avec sa barbe dos et
son cuir de russie alexander mcqueen lui
offre un verre et l'a félicité pour ses
dernières photos dans le voc john
galliano la laisse caresser son chien
yohji yamamoto souris se lève s'incline
et se rassoit qu'il s'endort raconte
potsdam avant la chute du mur de berlin
helmut lang s'exclame hello my dear
giorgio armani a salué dans les
backstage à h - dix minutes karl
lagerfeld affirme qu'elle est le nouveau
visage du millénaire qu elle est divine
ravissante ironique adorable il a
propulsé mariée de sa collection haute
couture valentino libère la main dolce &
gabbana déclare elle a une classe innée
une expression antique son visage est
celui d'une princesse de la renaissance
modère le complexe pour moutier à prada
elle à l'intelligence des caractères et
la qualité d'une star pour fernando elle
est juste un super quoi tirer
c'est très bien à votre bouquin c'est
d'abord c'était critères incluent
respectivement auprès de beigbeder
droite les stones avis vous citer des
marques que vous citer des noms propres
enfants ni ekwalla disons que pape a
parlé de marque pour un livre sur la
mode c'est un peu une faute
professionnelle donc c'est vrai que
c'est un peu obligé et puis c'est un
monde qui est complètement frénétique
complètement speed et on parle beaucoup
du festival de cannes mais c'est
vraiment tout le temps en 365 jours par
an c'est comme le festival de cannes
c'est un milieu où on est tout le temps
dans l'exagération le superlatif une
fille elle est pas simplement jolie elle
est extraordinaire c'est un casting qui
va changer ta vie enfin c'est tout et
l'exagération on est dopé en permanence
et c'est quelque chose de grisant
montrez votre livre ouais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu